اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
تقول ان اكثر من 20 دوله وافقت على
المشاركه في التحالف الجديد الذي تقوده
الولايات المتحده لحمايه حركه التجاره في
البحر الاحمر من هجمات انصار الله
الحوثيين برنامج الغذاء العالمي يقول ان
اكثر من ربع سكان غزه استنفذوا امدادات
الغذائيه وباتوا يواجهون خطر الموت جوعا
في ظل استمرار الحرب الاسرائيليه على
القطاع وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في
رابط بالتعليق الاول رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد الجيش في السودان عبد الفتاح
البرهان يتوعد بمحاسبه من وصفهم بالمتخيل
فيما حدث مؤخرا بمدينه وذ مدني عاصمه
ولايه الجزيره وسط البلاد والجيش يعلن
اجراءه تحقيقا في الاسباب والملابسات التي
ادت لانسحاب القوات من مواقعها خلال دخول
قوات الدعم السريع المدينه بعد معاركه مع
قوه من الجيش استمرت نحو اربعه
ايام محكمه اسلام اباد العليا ترفض
التماسا قدمه زعيم حزب انصاف الباكستاني
ورئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان لتعليق
حكم المحكمه الابتدائيه فيما تعرف بقضيه
توش خانا ما يمنع ترشحه للانتخابات العامه
المقبله وتوليه مناصب حكوميه ولا يزال
عمران خان يقبع في السجن بسبب قضيه يتهم
فيها بالكسب غير
المشروع اسعار الذهب ترتفع مدعومه بتراجع
الدولار وانخفاض عوائد سندات الخزانه
الامريكيه مع ترقب المتعاملين البيانات
الاقتصاديه من واشنطن بحثا عن مزيد من
الدلائل بشان توقعات قرارات السياسه
النقديه لمجلس الاحتياطي الاتحادي الى
اللقاء